[Música]
créanme que tengo la misma adrenalina en
este momento que cuando tengo que dar
una carrera es fabuloso
bueno vayamos al grano
como le comentaba miguel
nací en una familia muy guerrera como se
lo dicen
siempre me críe al lado de autos de
carrera de motores y bueno fue que me
despertó mi pasión por el automovilismo
por la velocidad y bueno fue así que a
los 12 años conseguí el grand permiso a
mi madre para poder empezar a correr y
bueno a los 12 años empecé a correr en
karting tuve la suerte de correr 6 años
pude lograr unos campeonatos así que
bueno la verdad que mi vida fue muy muy
linda en esa etapa
hasta que en el 2012 cuando tenía 18
años
en febrero de 2012 me detectaron un
linfoma de burkitt que eso es un tipo de
cáncer que afecta el sistema linfático
bueno en ese momento obviamente tuve que
dejar de traslado todas las cosas que
venía haciendo y bueno dedicarme a mi
vida que era lo que más necesitaba en
ese momento los médicos me dicen que lo
que para para poder sanar me iba a tener
que pasar por un tratamiento de
quimioterapia así que bueno no tenía
muchas opciones así que empecé ese
tratamiento en buenos aires
después de haber pasado eran seis
sesiones puede haber pasado la primera
tuvo una infección que entró a mi
organismo eso me afectó mucho así que
estuve 11 días en coma farmacológico
inducido bueno después con una
una bendición del señor siempre dije que
puede salir delante ese momento me pude
despertar que puede recuperar y bueno
fueron pasando los meses pude seguir con
el tratamiento y bueno al cabo de los
seis meses de que me habían
diagnosticado el cáncer estaba sano y ya
podría volver a misiones que bueno había
sido un tiempo largo que no podía volver
y retomar mi vida bueno ese año volví
era casi mitad de año y bueno comencé a
trabajar con mi padre lo que queda del
año y obviamente quería volver a
corrernos que era lo que es lo que más
me motiva cuando estaba internado quería
volver a correr así que bueno me hice
todos los controles previos me habían
dado todo bien así que los médicos me
permitieron volver a correr
bueno ese año pude disputar las últimas
dos fechas del campeonato y bueno muy
rápido se fue ese año vino el 2013 y
bueno tenía pensado estudiar entonces
ingresé en la facultad de economía en la
unam e posadas y bueno habíamos decidido
con con mis padres que lo mejor era que
estudie y que deje de lado por un tiempo
la carrera que me dedique a lo que tenía
que hacer en su momento quiere estudiar
y bueno entonces empecé a estudiar y
bueno lo cierto es que en el mayo de ese
año del 2013
empecé a tener algunos problemas no me
sentía bien entonces veamos unos
análisis de sangre
y bueno en los análisis estaban muy mal
dieron valores muy muy muy mal tenía
todo le compensara los glóbulos blancos
con los rojos así que me llevan de
urgencia buenos aires de vuelta al
hospital italiano mi interna buenos
pasos cinco días ahí en terapia y
después de unos días me informan que lo
que yo tenía era cáncer de la sangre que
se llama leucemia
así que bueno fue un momento muy duro
para mí otra vez tenía que dejar de lado
todo lo que venía haciendo toda mi
perspectiva que tenía y enfocarme de
vuelta en mí en mi salud
y los médicos me informan de vuelta que
no iba a tener que hacer un tratamiento
de quimioterapia
y para sanarme al 100% y van a necesitar
un trasplante de médula
bueno en ese momento obviamente muy
decaído estaba muy muy mal
emocionalmente mi familia también toda
la gente que me rodeaba así que
y bueno los médicos llaman a mi hermanos
para que sea el análisis de
compatibilidad porque los hermanos
tienen un 25 por ciento probabilidades y
los padres sus 5 bueno se hacen y no
ninguno de ellos era compatible
entonces va a tener que buscar en alguna
parte del mundo alguien que tenga 100%
compatibilidad bueno esta noticia se
corrió muy rápido con las redes sociales
entonces el misión es mucha gente quería
ayudar se realiza una campaña con el
banco de sangre de la provincia
se realizó no verá en el logra trick
club una campaña inmensa mucha gente se
acercó a colaborar imagínense que estaba
pactada para un día y se tuvo que seguir
el otro día porque había mucha gente que
había quedado afuera que tenía ganas de
hacerse el análisis y lo pudo por el
tiempo así que fue una una una campaña
muy grande bueno después de eso a todo
esto estaban buenos aires me informan de
unos días pues también que bueno que no
había nadie y era compatible conmigo de
todas esas personas vieran cerca de
donar
y bueno de todas maneras yo seguía con
mi tratamiento esperando a la espera de
alguna alguna alguna persona que sea
compatible conmigo y así que el 6 de
agosto de ese año una mañana ya mandé al
hospital y nos informan qué
que habían encontrado a una persona en
alemania una persona que tenía 30 años
es que era 100 compatible con mi médula
y que estaba dispuesto a hacer el
trasplante bueno rápidamente
imagínense alegría era como ve de cartel
de última vuelta en una carrera sabía
que faltaba poco para la bandera a
cuadros así que bueno estaba muy
motivado
los médicos rápidamente planifican
califica en trasplantes y bueno
mexicanos como hace todo el proceso en
que se basaba y el 23 de agosto bueno
pude hacerme el trasplante recibir esa
médula que tanto esperabas bueno unos
meses después tuve un par de
complicaciones pero por suerte pude
salir adelante todo con solución y bueno
para finalizar el 2012 ya estaba el 2013
perdón estaba en mi casa pasando con mi
familia el último día del año regresé a
a mi casa bueno el año siguiente seguí
con controles pero iba todo muy bien así
que obviamente de vuelta quería volver a
correr bueno después de una larga lucha
con mi madre no hay todos los médicos
tratando de cambiar mi pasión pero como
todos saben eso no se cambia
no lograron y cambio de porte entonces
bueno me dieron la autorización de poder
volver a correr y bueno pude volver a
las pistas que era lo que tanto en el
lado fue un tiempo
había algo como que todo ese proceso que
había pasado todas esas cosas magníficas
cosas que había pasado
había algo que no me cerraba como que
tenía que me faltaba algo me faltaba una
porción de todo eso que no me termina de
cerrar entonces pensaba y pensaba y si
realmente él no me faltaba era ayudar a
la otra otra otra gente como toda una
comunidad tuvo conmigo yo tenía que
devolverle algo de eso
a esa gente rey no iban a ser los mismos
pero si quería ayudar a esa gente que
estaba pasando por un momento difícil
como el qué
tuve la experiencia yo así que bueno
dije bueno voy a empezar a ir a visitar
a este tipo de gente que está pasando en
una situación difícil y bueno tratar de
motivarnos para que se adelante y pensé
y decía bueno voy a ir le voy a decir
que bueno que el de meta para adelante
que tengan fuerzas que ánimo que todo se
puede salir pero después también me di
cuenta que eso le puede decir cualquier
persona cualquier persona que había
pasado por una situación así que no le
va a decir algo a eso no algo como eso
así que pensé me dije no si voy y le
digo eso no le va a llenar no le va a
llenar a esa persona entonces empecé a
investigar a interiorizarme más en el
tema y empecé a ver que tenían las
personas que sí salieron adelante que la
que no tenían y que no tenían las
personas que no pudieron salir adelante
entonces empecé a mirar videos a buscar
en internet a charlan con gente que
había pasado por estas mismas cosas
y entre todos todas las personas me
ayudaron a identificar estos encontramos
tres claves se podría llamar claves o
pasos
y estos tres son son el primero es la
aceptación
todos tenemos que aceptar el momento que
estamos viviendo por más difícil que sea
tenemos que aceptarlo sé que es muy dura
la realidad a veces pero no nos sirve de
nada pelear contra la realidad es muy
inútil es gastar energías
el segundo paso de la actitud debemos
tener una actitud positiva ante las
cosas por más dura que sea la situación
tenemos que tener una actitud de
luchador de salir adelante obviamente
que la actitud más fácil es la de
bueno este es mi destino de lamentarme
todo pero no nos va a servir para salir
adelante sí o sí tenemos que tener una
lucha
de luchador de querer salir de querer
lograr los objetivos y por último una de
las más importante consideró que la
motivación todas las personas tenemos
algo que nos motiva algo que nos lleva a
movernos movilizarnos y bueno es de eso
que en estas situaciones difíciles las
situaciones límites nos tenemos que
aferrar por más dolorosa que estemos que
sea la situación tenemos que aferrarnos
a eso y saber que eso es lo único que
nos puede sacar adelante pensar en esa
cosa que nos motiva ya sea un familiar
un amigo o una mascota un deporte
confort mi caso el dolor también puede
ser todas esas tres cosas son
fundamentales para poder ser elegante no
solo en algo como me pasó a mí con la
salud sino en todos los ámbitos la vida
sea económico o sea un problema familiar
todas las personas tenemos problemas
encontré eso en todas las personas que
pudieran ser garantes contra esas tres
claves espero que les sirva a ustedes lo
que la vida me enseñó a mismo y para
finalizar quería decirle algo desde lo
más profundo de mi corazón que el cáncer
que no se le deseo a nadie pero estoy
muy agradecido de haber pasado por eso
me enseñó un montón de cosas he
aprendido cosas me ha mostrado la vida
cosas que capaz de en otra situación no
lo habéis aprendido y bueno para eso
estoy muy agradecido gracias
[Música]